شات جي بي تي يصدم العالم بذكاء فوق
المتوقع واثرياء ومسؤولين العالمي يطلبون
منه المساعده والقصه الكامله لامتحان
دانيال بالاعتداء الجنسي واعتقاله ومصريه
تحكي عن انقاذها لاسره من الغرق والسلطات
وسكان المنطقه يؤكدون ما حصلش اهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
من اقل من شهرين كنا في تفاعلكم من اوائل
من بدا الكلام عن
برمجه الاصطناعي اللي طورتها شركه اوبن اي
اي وطرحتها لاستخدمه الناس نهايه العام
الماضي وفجر الجدل واسع حول خطورهتها على
مهن كثيره
وقدرتها تحديدا على الاجابه على اسئله
وتنفيذ مهام في مختلف المجالات والقلق
اللي سببته على مستقبل الكثير من الامور
ومنهم مثلا التعليم التعليم وناقشنا وقتها
اليوم
بقوه جدا والسبب ان البرنامج هي اللي
بنتكلم عنها نجحت في مجموعه من الامتحانات
وخلت العالم كله ياخذ وقفه يعني كده
وينصدم يعني الناس كانت عارفه ذكيه او
متطوره بس انه هذه الدرجه وبهذه بسرعه
نجح في اختيار اختبار ام بي اي في كليه
الوطن العريق استاذ كمال مجموعه من
اختبارات رخصه الطب في ولايات امريكيه
ونجاح كمان في اختبار ماده بزنس اوبريشن
ونجح في امتحان مزاوله محاك كمان يعني شيء
مرعب بصراحه بس خلينا يعني كده للتذكير
سريع عن البرمجيه هي عباره عن بوت شات
عادي يعني بنفتحوه كانك بتكلم شخص وبتبعث
اسئلتك او طلباتك بيرد عليك يعني طيب هذه
التطورات الجديده السريعه كلها استدعت
مننا وقفه جديده عشان نفهم لجئنا للدكتور
محمد قاسم واللي بالمناسبه هو المستخدميه
ومن المبسوطين فيه جدا من الكويت بينضم
الينا دكتور محمد قاسم عضو مجلس اداره
المدرسه الرقم في كليه الدراسات
التكنولوجيا اهلا فينا احلى فيك معانا يا
دكتور
تعبك الكبير بالشات جي بي تي
والله صراحه سهل علي حياتي بشكل كبير جدا
اهلا ساره كيف حالك
طبعا حاليا لسوا انا الوحيد اللي مستمتع
فيه الكثير من الناس قاعدين يستخدم
فتره بسيطه احد الاشخاص بين كيف يستخدم
شخصيات ومن الشخصيات يطلب مننا التكوين
جمل لهم ثم ياخذ هذه الجمل ويحطها في
متجرني وتطلع لي رسمات وياخذ الرسمات ويحط
عليه تي شيرتات ويروح في ناس حتى ماديه
يعني
في نفس الوقت احنا بنشوف هذا الشيء طيب
هذا كمان في قتل كثير من الوظائف الحاليه
اللي موجوده كمان في قتل فكره الابداع
البشريه يعني عشره سنين من هذه الاستخدام
الناس هتصير اغبيه يعني خلص ما حد يبغى
يفكر يعني ههه
يا صحيح هذه نحن المشكله الحين قاعدين
يواجهونا في التعليم في ناس قاعدين
يستخدمون لكتابه المقالات بس خليني اصلح
شغله بسيطه انا طلعت على الاوراق العلميه
اللي سوت الفحص للاختبارات هذه كبار
الباركزام
والطيب وكذلك الانبياء هذه الاختبارات
مثلا في المحاماه تجاوز بعض لانه طبعا في
كذا باب من ابواب الاختبارات اقزام فتجاوز
بعضها وبعضها ما نجح فيك ولازال لما
تشوفين البار جرافس تلاحظين ان البشر لا
زالوا متفوقين على ساجد كثير ولو
وصل الى مرحله متقدمه بحيث انه يحل
الاختبارات كامله
يا سلام عليك بالضبط هذا الكلام الصحيح
خلال سنوات القادمه يعني احنا ما قاعدين
نتكلم عن 20 سنه الى الامام قاعدين نتكلم
عن اشهر جي بي تي فور كالمفروض ينزل هذا
الشهر لكن اوبن اعلنت قبل كم يوم انك خلاص
لا ما راح ننزله بنخليه بعد كم شهر لحد ما
نتاكد انه ما في مشاكل ما تصير حديث
استخدامه ونشا قالوا هالكلام طبعا جي بيتي
ثلاثه والان جي بي تي اربعه يبون يتاكدوا
منها
ولكن كلامك صحيح احنا الان قاعدين نخدوا
خطوات قاعدين شوي شوي شوي شوي نستحوذ على
اماكن كان مرتاح فيها الانسان الان انت
تاخذين منه المحاما ممكن تاخذي من الطب
طبعا حاليا ممكن نستغل
والاشياء مثل هذه لصالحنا لتسريع بعض
العمليات وبعض الاشياء اللي قاعدين نسوي
لكن في المستقبل
ممكن يحل مكانه بكل اكيد
الكل الان يعني يفكر في كيف يستخدمها بحيث
انه يكون وضعك بعدين الدكتور محمد يعني
كمان واحده من اهم المشاكل الي بتواجهنا
الان انه الناس بطلت تبغى تجلس تفكر او
تبحث او يعني تصنيف الامور او ترتب الامور
وكده لما احد يجي يديها شيء على الجاهز
ترى لا احد يبحث ولا حد يفكر ولا احد
هيسوي ترى مستقبل مظلم
عاوز اشوفك انا اتفق معاك تماما احنا هذه
المشكله لازم نحلها وين نحلها في بدايات
يعني المكان الاساسي اللي نبدا فيها الحل
هي من خلال التعليم لازم نعلم الانسان انه
ما يعتمد اعتماد كلي على هذه الاشياء انما
يعتمد على نفسه وياخذ معاونه
جدك في الانسان لهذه الدرجه لانه
الاستسقال سمه يعني الكثير من الاشياء في
هذه الايام بس يعني خليني اقول لك صراحه
الموضوع مبهر يعني اغنى رجل في اسيا يعني
همم طعمه اللي هو ثاني برده هو كمان صرح
ان هو مدمن عليه وانه يعني
حتى احنا شايفين على الشاشه الموضوع ده بس
في كثير ومسؤولين كبار صرحوا انهم
بيستخدموه حتى في كتابه ايميلات الشغل
وخطابات رسميه يعني انت بتخلي درجنا احنا
وصلنا يعني هذول الناس مثلا حتى عندهم احد
يكتب لهم هذه الاشياء ومع ذلك هم
بالطبع يعني انا طبعا مستغرب
120 مليار دولار وقاعد على جيبوتي لكن
فكري
فيها انه الناس اللي قاعدين يشتغلون حوله
واللي كانوا يكتبوا لنا ايميلات ساعدونا
في تصحيحها او مشابه الان اصبح هذا ممكن
ياخذ المحلاتيه لان صراحه وعيد اسهل يعانه
اني استخدمتي على اني ابحث على شخص يعاوني
في هذا الموضوع فتخيل يعني السوق كيف راح
يتاثر وكيف تتغير موازين العمل في
المستقبل لازم نفكر نعيد التفكير مره
ثانيه في طرق جديده وابداعات جديده جديده
بحيث نصل الى امكانيات واعمال جديده غير
متوقعه اعطيك انا مثال يعني حاليا اللي
بدات فيها انه شخص يستخدم
هاه يعيش انا اعتقد ممكن الانسان انه يبدع
وينتج نعم يعني يحتاج اعاده يعني تفكير
ووقفه كمان في الموضوع للتوازن طبعا كان
معنا من الكويت دكتور محمد قاسم عضو مجلس
اداره المدرسه الرقميه واستاذ سابق في
كليه الدراسات التكنولوجيه شكرا لك
اشعار اول بيت اطلقت وزاره الثقافه
السعوديه الحدث الاول من نوعه في العالم
ولاول مره بنالي الفنون الاسلاميه في هذا
البناء اليوم معرض فني كبير وعاده يطلق
على المعارض اللي بتخان كل سنتين ومن كل
سنه بدات اقامت معارض من هذا النوع في
السعوديه او البيت مش بين الفن المعاصر
والثقافه الاسلام وبيشكل نقطه وصل بين
الماضي
والحاضر عبر اعمال فنيه وتاريخيه متميزه
الحدث انطلق امس في صاله الحجاج الغربيه
بمطار الملك عبد العزيز بجده وبيستمر
لغايه 23 ابريل وسمي اول بيت في اشاره
للكعبه المشرفه او يشارك فيه عدد من
الفنانين السعوديين والعالمين بدون معارض
واثار ومقتنيات بتعرض حتى
للمره الاولى يعني فخلينا من مقر بناء
زميلنا مراسل العربيه سلطان سليمان الينا
اهلا فيك معانا سلطان ظلمت الدنيا شويه
حوالينك بس انا عارفه انك انت هناك من
بدري وتقدر تحكي لنا عن مشاهداتك
ساره اهلا بكافه المشاهدين بالفعل معرض
بنالي
للفنون الاسلاميه نتحدث على معرض ضخم يقع
على مساحه
188,000 متر مربع ان يتحدث على خمس صلاه
عرض جناح جناحين منها جناح مخصص لمكه
وجناح مخصص للمدينه المنوره تواجد في
الصاله واحد قبل نبدا جولتنا لفت نظري هذا
العمل الفني الملفت جدا نتحدث انه هذا
العمل قام به مهندس الصوت امريكي مسلم
عباره عن 19 اذان من 19 مسجد في 19 دوله
مختلفه دمج الاصوات ليظهر الصوت في تزامل
واحد وقت واحد عنده اصول الزائد عند اي
واحده من السماعات هذه ساره هيسمع تونس
ونغمه مختلفه او صوت مختلفه لكن تظهر
للعموم كانها صوت واحد ايضا همم في داخل
هذه الصاله نتحدث على تفاصيل واعمال مهمه
نتحدث اكثر من 500
ااا فنيه داخل هذا المعرض نتحدث على اكثر
من 40 الفنان من مختلف دول العالم وتحديدا
من 23 دوله عالميه و18 همم
فنان سعودي هذا المعرض يحمل في طيات وفي
معارضه الخمس وجناحيه عدد كبير من القطع
النادره والفنيه التي تحكي همم فنون
العالم الاسلامي ومجتمعات العالم الاسلامي
قديما هنالك قطع تعود لالاف السنين وقطع
نادره واصليه لاول مره تعرض في هذا المعرض
الكبير الذي سوف يستمر لمده ثلاثه اشهر
وسوف يعود مجددا هذا المعرض بعد عامين في
جده ليعرض هذه الفنون وهذه القطعه النادره
هنالك همم اعمال ومجسمات وقطع وهمم يعني
اجنده مكتوبه وكذلك اعمال اسلاميه مختلفه
تحكي تاريخ الاسلامي تحكي المجتمعات
الاسلاميه قديما
ملفت ان هنالك اعداد كبيره من الزوار
والمهتمين بالفنون من مختلف دول العالم
حضروا اليوم او اتجهت بوصلتهم الى جده
للمشاهده هذه العماله لارض الواقع كما
تشاهدون الجميع يعني همم يعني تلفوا هذه
الانظار بالتقطون الصور الناس بتدور
المعلومات الخاصه
بهذا المرض سبيل المثال هذا عمل فنان من
دوله بنجلاديش يتحدث انه في السابق عندما
كان المسلمين يريدون الذهاب الى مكه لاداء
فريضه الحج كانوا يغرقون في احد الانهار
الضخمه مما جعله يعملون هذه او نموذج
لتثبت بها بشكل كبير وعدم الغرق هذه
القطعه التي تشاهدها في الاعلى هي قطعه
نحاسيه مملوكه للاهل الذين توفوا داخل هذا
النهار انا ذاك في قبل مده طويله ايضا
الاداء المعارض اليوم مساحه كبيره منها
جدا ميزه هذا كانوا تم تصميمه بشكل مناسب
جدا حتى في ما يتعلق بالمؤثرات الصوتيه
وحتى تم توزيع الاضاءات بشكل لا تؤذي همم
القطع الفنيه المعروضه ايضا هنالك عمال
تحكي قصص فنانين وكذلك تحكي نماذج للعيش
سابقا في وقت همم
يعني فيما مضى بسنوات طويله جدا اريد ان
اخذكم ايضا في قسم اخر يحكي عن عمل فني
لفنان همم مغربي كلنا من تراب وضع العديد
من الطوب كما نسميه باللهجه العاميه لكن
بالوان مختلفه همم جدا تحدث انه ليس هنالك
عنصريه في في الاسلام لذلك انه يشاهد هذا
العمل خلال ثواني قادما ننتقل لان المعرض
ما شاء الله حجمه كبير جدا لذلك ان نستطيع
المشي فيه ساعات طويله هيك الفعاليات ورش
العمل والجلسات الثقافه
خارج هذا المعرض في الساحات او في الباجات
بس قبل الختام ساره هذا العمل الذي كنت
تحكي عنه قبل قليل هو عمل فنان مغربي صنع
هذا مختلفه حتى يحكي انه كلنا من طين او
من تراب
السياسيه
احنا بنشكرك يعني على هذه الجوله الاكثر
من رائعه وصراحه ادعوا الناس انهم يروحوا
للمعرض صراحه واضح انه جميل جدا وان شاء
الله كلنا زياره كان معنا من مقر بناني
جده زميلنا مراسل العربيه
في برشلونه
تهم الاعتداء الجنسي ما بيترتب عليها
اعتقال فوري فليش اعتقل داني البس على طول
سبب الاعتقال ويفق وسائل الاعلام هو
التضارب روايات ثانيه فاول ما طلعت القصه
نفاها تماما وقال مو صحيح ورجع بعدها
بتصريحات للاعلام اكد انه كان سهران مع
اصحابه في نفس المكان يومها لكنها
الاعتداء على البنت او انه شافها او اي
شيء وفي التحقيقات مع السلطات اعترف ان هو
يعرف البنت انه فعلا صار بينهم شيء
ولكنها تضارب الروايات هذه هي اللي وراء
اعتقاله طيب اما الين ما سمح القاضي
بكفاءه ففي كذا سيناريو محتمل الاول هو
الخوف من انه يهرب بره البلد خاصه انه
قادر يعملها والثاني انه بعد ما سمع
القاضي اقوال داني والشهود والمدعيه ضد حس
انه مو ممكن الافراج عنه
عموما القضيه كلها
عرضت الازياء الشهيره جوانا ساندي اللي في
بدايه الامر دعمته وتحديدا قبل الاع قالوا
ونشرت صوره لهم سووا و علقت عليها وكتبت
معا وحتى في مقابله دافعت عنه وقالت اعرفه
اعرف قديش محترم خاصه مع النساء رجعت
بعدها ونشرت مناشده للصحافه والكاميرات
انه يمشوا من امام منزلها ويحترموا اللي
بتمر فيه خاصه انه امها توفت من اسبوع بس
وقالت نصا خسرت عمودي حياتي الوحيده وكيله
اعمال زوج الداني السابق كمان طلعت في
تصريحات ودافعت عنه بتعيش كابوس من وقت
الخبر وانه اداني ولا يمكن يعمل شيء مثل
هذا لانه بتعرفه من 22 سنه وتزوجته 10
سنين منه وسائل الاعلام بتتكلم كمان انه
الفتاه اللي بتتهموه للسلطات اسمها او
صورتها بلغت امن لها فورا باللي صار انه
طلبوا الشرطه لكن لما وصلت كان ثاني غدر
المكان
مكسيكي اللي بيلعب فيه ثاني فسخ تعاقده
معه على الفور وقال لي انه بياكد التزام
وبي عدم التسام مع اي تصرفات من قبل اي
فرد مهما كانت شخصيته اي هذه التصرفات
اللي بتتعارض طبعا مع روح النادي وقيامه
الازمه طالت طيب كمان شبه نادي برشلونه او
اللاعب الاسباني الشهير السابق واللي كان
زميل داني ايام ما كان بيلعبوا في برشلونه
ومدرب ولاحقا لفتره قصيره كمان هو طالته
هذه الازمه ففي مؤتمر صحفي من يومين ان
سال عن الموضوع وقال انه متفاجئ ومظلوم من
الاخبار وانه بيشعر بالاسف على ذلك الدنيا
ضدهم من اعتبره تصريحه تعاطف مع داني وانه
ما جاب سيره الضحيه ابدا الفضل العشابي في
تصريحات جديده وقدم اعتذاره ووضح وقال انه
كلام
واضح انه غلط انه ما جاب سيره الضحيه
بريطانيا
ده بتاع محمد
[موسيقى]
رئيسه المجلس القومي للمراه مايا مرسي
وعنوان وبطله الجمهوريه وبطله الشرقيه
ومضمون وانقاذ سيده اسمها اماني محمد
لاسره كامله من الغرق البوس هذا عمل ضجه
كبيره
وتبحث عن اماني محمد وسائل الاعلام
بطولاتها وانجازاتها وفيديوهات مقابله
تحملات المنصات وكمان العربيه حتى
تفاصيل القصه
انت متجه عن طريق المنيا القمح وكنت راكبه
تورته وقال لي من الابتدائي مفيش اي مشكله
من الاتجاه الثاني وبعدين لقينا ناس
ملمومه ولقينا العربيه في نص البحر اخذت
بعدي وقمت جايه باسال واحد كان واقف شخص
كان واقف بقول له الله يكون صحاب العربيه
قال لي لا يكون صحابها ازاي وهو صاحب
العربيه فيها وانت بتتكلم وانا بتهزر بجد
قال لي هي دي فيها حاجه هزار اخذت بعض
طبعا ومسكت حديده من شخص كان واقف
البحر لحد ما وصلت للعربيه
وبعدين طلعت الالوان خالص همم
عملت لهم اسعافات اوليه طبعا في ساعه
نزولي اكيد البحر خالص
ان انا يعني هيحصل للموقف ده اه نحطها على
بطنهم لحد ما الميه طلعت واخذت بعده
محليهم المستشفى والحمد لله طلعت بخير
واهل الاطفال شطه اثنين
وطلع لي المبلغ اخذته طبعا وبعدين برده
لما عرف انه ان انا زعلانه
همم وقال لي الاسره الكريمه وهزارك بكره
ان شاء الله
اماني سيد عمري 28 سنه من سكان الشرقيه
وقالت انها نطت في الترعه وكسرت زجاج
السياره الغارق وطلعت اللي فيها او مو بس
كده كمان عملت لهم اسعافات اوليه كل هذا
الوحده والناس واقفه بس بتتفرج وما ساعدها
طبعا هذا كله حسب روايه اماني كلامها عمل
ضجه كبيره خاصه بعد ما الاعلام توجه لجهه
الرسميه يستفسر والسلطات بدورها نفذ
الواقعه تماما وقالت انه ما في اي بلاغه
تقدم بالواقع اللي بتتكلم عنها امانه وحتى
المستشفى اللي قالت انها تم نقلهم عليها
قالوا ما وصلت اللي عندهم اي حالات لغرق
او مصابين في حادث انقلاب سياره طيله
الايام الماضيه بعدها جاءت عاد روايات
الناس اللي في المنطقه واللي كانت هي كمان
صادمه وقالت انه ما صار شيء من هذا النوع
في المنطقه ابدا ابدا يعني فيلم عربي من
الوزن الثقيل وفضيحه وعليها شهود تصوير
مشاهد بطوليه من الدرجه الاولى وبعد كل
هذا القصه طلعت مخبركه وم لقاء من خيال
اماني ويعني نقدر نسميها بطله من ورق او
من وحي الخيال والوحم وما في اي دليل واضح
على انه القصه صارت وحتى الاسره اللي
انقذتها مو مبينه هذا غير تداول اخبار انه
في امراه كمان طلبت منها امانه تشهد انه
الواقعه صارت وتاخذ 100,000 جنيه مقابل
ذلك وعموما حتى ما يا مرسي رئيسه المجلس
القومي للمراه بعد كل هذا مساحات البوست
اللي نشرتته اما الدوافع حتى هذه اللحظه
مجهوله
[موسيقى]
انا مشاهدينا احنا وصلنا لختام حلقه اليوم
ونعود والقاكم غدا ان شاء الله في حلقه
جديده من تفاعلكم في امان الله
[موسيقى]